[Music]
hey come on get your stuff let's
go let's try that
again
a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who
were running out of it until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want for
me New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you why who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all day
what do you want me you have no idea
what those girls have come why don't
you I think he can see into the future
are he's trying to change what
happens Julia get
down your future was almost so different
do if you want to live you have to trust
me
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little I have to convince a certain
person that the Buy in that trunk out
there is indeed Rolo something happened
to his
face what the it's Miss along with the
rest of his
head betrayal is a funny thing it's very
naturous to catch you
unaware you ever heard a ring
doorbell we're under
attack stance
gone and you should be too I've always
heard one rule shall be good to the
people who were good to you be good to
yourself Charlie and get as far away
from here as you
can turned on your own he to get out of
buuy CH that's what everyone keeps
telling
me that 50 Grand could really change
things for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you last Charlie I got more men than you
got bullets bullets are easy to
get what do you want you not breathing
and how you going to do that I'm doing
it for a long you know you really ought
to start thinking about an Exit Plan
what are you waiting
for pull the trigger
[Music]
Charlie you're in over your
head I don't like
loose he was my second best guy I'm
looking forward to meeting number one
for a
long oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size 4S huh are you so big look at the
big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
down up on a six sorry about the mess
hold
on oh hey Bo hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy look to God we're
going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collaborate and listen I is
back with a brand new
5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a car
can someone unlock the car
please call in
everybody I want him
F what was that little pothole Maxi's
been up the whole time by the
way when I A Melody anything is wish
that before I met your mom I was a
covert assassin I escaped that life and
now they found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us look at you blind of family man I'm
not playing is my
life hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait wait
[Music]
go new
record enterment
oh yeah I'm the king of
Atlantis you true king builds Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges during King Alan's time there
were Seven Kingdoms and the Trident was
a curse upon them
all the tridon dark magic is spreading
he means to end the bloodline two of you
standing together
Brothers promise me you will protect
each
other I don't know what lies ahead but
we can't leave our children in a world
without
Hope G
yeah you know I got a bunch ofing [__]
to do
go hey head of the wedding of my sister
yes I am so where's your fiance wait is
this him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass
on your break wow you are a child it's a
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smell like against
security nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this
girl's a
[Applause]
disastrous been our wedding
sorry is's it going stranger what's
going on over there they dated she
crushed his heart that man does not have
a
heart no way honey look who's here who
is this my ex Jonathan my parents have
been trying to get us back together he's
like a son to us maybe we should just
tell everyone we're together what it
would solve that problem for me and you
clearly want Margaret she seesure with
me she wants what she can't have there's
no way we can convince anyone we
actually like each other you know I
still think about that night we spent
together shut up no I'm
serious no matter how it ended it's
still pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do it
honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben so
is it like we just got together or we'
been sneaking around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted not a magic
lamp hey little guy God damn
it we have to kick it up a not nice T
nice oh no no it's going to be hot when
are you ever going to learn [__] it it's
fine yes I know that
Titanic me are they watching are they
doing Titanic they're gone show's over
oh my
god do you have a mo or something on
your butt
no what
theck what the one might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
[__] it it's
fine
[Music]
you
oh
oh hi there little
[Music]
buddy you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more
and that's how I adopted
John okay now have you ever been with a
PL no please no ow it's so hot it's
really hurting ow ow ow you deserve to
[Music]
be say when never John bury me in cheese
oh I apologize in advance the eating
you're about to see will not be pretty
and if you have young children this
would be a good time for them to leave
the room never seen nobody
this hey Junior this is fck my father
you ever jump to train I've never jumped
here's that stop really
where oh OD you think he'd see that
coming let's get it deserve to be with
somebody me
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you it's going to be another
hot one out there in fact there are heat
alerts in effect for New Jersey feeling
like
[Music]
100° what is that
that
for the first time in New York history
people frose to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear ducts freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
oh hell
no [__] move hey PG-13
please what was that oh lord it's the
queen bee Regina George don't look her
in the eye you could be really hot if we
change like everything
met welcome to Health and Human
Sexuality we'll be getting into
abstinence of course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet Baby
E we as women have to be able to support
each other get in loser welcome Katie
never going to believe what I found this
morning your burn book mom go make
snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah do you like gum sure oh no I don't
have any I was just you're a mess we
will help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
[__] that is [__] shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her pay
all we've done is to make Regina hotter
and revive the wet look dance
break who wrote all this
[Music]
junk K pushed her Regina really should
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't even
see it like a face
breast
incorrect you have to pick a French name
Chanel
No No
[Music]
beon our little girls growing up so fast
and things couldn't be
better what is
that okay let's clear it all out it's
demo
day demo wait what's happening who are
you
people what's going
on wait wait you
can't hey hey what are you doing all
right she's all set that with
what orange who made the console orange
do I look orange I didn't touch it
orange is not my color not
me hello oh my gosh I'm anxiety where
can I put my stuff a new emotion wow oh
I'm sorry we wanted to make such a good
first impression what do you mean
we
[Music]
how does it feel being back good I had
such good memories here maybe my happy
place can be our happy place we left you
all alone down
here I'm playing a new game with chy the
scavenger hunt list that's fun Chanty
says you're not allowed to play with us
oh because you left him I need something
happy something
happy G I thought bugs freaked you out
if I can finish my list try will take me
on a trip to the place he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice you've been spending time with a
new friend
no
me he asked you to do something that
hurt you that was part of the game does
that seem like a game a good friend
would want to play maybe we shouldn't
play together anymore johy maybe we
shouldn't be friends no no
no Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice
she's lost but we're going to find
her every culture has entities that
tether to the young we call them
imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
enraged he says he's right behind
you but it was just myag
can I hang out with your imaginary
friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
friend we all know anything can happen
out there sometimes we feel
lost we push and we
suffer we keep going that makes all the
difference hey what happened to you boy
you don't look so good meatball look
somebody likes my meatballs hey Paw
Patrol we got a race to win just
remember Michael this race doesn't
Define you I raced for 19 years this is
my last chance to win 3 2 there's a
young boy living in the city all they do
was over the next 10 days these athletes
will cross 400 Mi climbing biking and
kaying that dot is Daddy go Daddy
D let's talk again the meatball super 3
days and 200 miles ago leave the stupid
dog and let's go come on move D talk
what is it boy oh oh God can't believe I
almost walked right off that Cliff extra
meatballs for you my
friend he's hurting what do you think he
went through before he met us whatever
it was it wasn't good how the hell did
he get all the way from here to there
while we were on bikes and zip lines and
running and climbing he must have wings
we don't know about boy you know I'm
back like I never left you want to try
to embrace the buckets of pain I need a
bigger bucket team broad rail has
traveled over 200 miles and they found a
companion Daddy has a dog what have you
done think you found your new partner in
suffering Michael yeah he's the king I
think we should call him Arthur Arthur
the king
sure how's he doing he's been through so
much this B needs a bit I don't want you
to hurt
anymore he's a
fighter just like
you famous dog looks even worse than the
rest of you maybe you all deserve each
other always underestimated nor my
buddy this isn't the route on the map
it's okay just follow Arthur lead the
way
[Music]
King I've never seen anything like guess
everybody knows about
[Music]
it guess what I'm not a dog
person this is not my
[Music]
world I've never been to this Lake
before never walked its Shores
but I will find my way back and I will
find my way back to my
Molly 5 years ago I was left in this
dark
place taken from my
[Music]
wife the people here have no hope you
still looking for that wife of yours
you're clinging to scraps of rumors and
then he
arrived
where's my wife I shifted her for every
choice you make there are countless
other realities we make a different
choice we talking about parallel Earths
imagine having the power to move people
from One reality to the next to shift
down what do you want with me I can make
you a king imagine everything you have
ever
wanted
work for me and get back with the woman
that you love okay we go on a date and
maybe we kiss hopefully he's might to
shift you back to your wife some
trick I choose you that's the last
Choice I'm ever going to
make I will never leave you
alone I've seen a bunch of people like
us out there looking for a little help
there is nothing that I won't do to
you you can't just shoot the
devil there is so much evil and
inhumanity in this world but there is
also Beauty and hope and I will find my
way back to her
hi I'm Elizabeth tabish and I'm so
excited for you guys to see my latest
project from Angel Studios I play Molly
Garner in the shift which comes out this
December Angel Studios theatrical
releases have always sold out the first
weekend so be sure to get your tickets
now you can get them at angel.com
theift here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dam what is this place we are completely
lost was you
mother that is not your
mother we're trying to get to Jamaica
so
simple don't worry Chum's gotcha so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry I thought your name was Chum yeah
chump yeah that's my name what right so
listen chump what did you just call me
I'm sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
[Music]
what this isn't about migration it's
about Adventure wo wo wo wo
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that duck laange what's
duck
laange it's you with laange on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and
we when danger
strikes you do not run from me
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
[Music]
Adventure you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am
I huh
go go
[Music]
[Applause]
go Mommy how was Nebraska it was
[Music]
um the
usual Mr bracket can you tell us what
happened that night at the hotel it was
our anniversary so we wanted to go out I
won't be me me you won't be you just two
strangers meeting in a
bar tomorrow
night I'm Jack Alice do you and your
wife role play often what exactly is
this about do you know this man no Jack
Bob Bob Jack pleasure he just talked for
5 minutes to all the victims of her
charms and then he
left the one and only hey where are you
I'll be right back
the wife's real name is Anna Peller
wanted for contract killings across
several
continents I'm
sorry
what they told me what you are my wife
is an
assassin this is a lot you kill people
it's over I never wanted to lie to you I
just want a normal life that I have a
family to protect you're my wife I am
coming to help you do not come here do
you hear me do not come
here I love you and I love our family we
can get through this we are concerned
about your wife and the safety of your
family she kills me this one I told you
I need out I'll bring the whole world
down on your
[Music]
heads I love you I have to go to work
now though okay
never a
girl killing is bad like unacceptably
bad I know I know I'm done done I
[Music]
swear
h
[Music]
and
child
[Music]
Santa
marry Christmas Gotham City in breaking
news Gotham is officially Crime Free as
best B man continues to clean it
up Dad I'm ready to be a superhero like
you
woohoo Merry Christmas
kiddo my own utility belt which should
only be used in case of a bat emergency
oh come on dad I'm not a baby hey I
never said you were a baby emergency
call for help my precious little baby is
in
danger it's the Justice League sorry
Damien I got to go shall I assume we did
not see the bat razor I like it totally
UPS my intimidation game you have donut
crumbs in your intimidation
games I promise I'll be back before
Christmas oh man I'm the worst dad
ever Jingle Bells backman Smells Robin L
egg Joker oh how I want to make this a
very special Christmas Eve and what
better way to do it than by stealing
Christmas I have to show Dad I can
handle myself wo it's a bit saggy well
that one just leaves nothing to the
imagination dad made me a bat
suit
awesome wait until they get a load of
me you don't have what it takes to be a
superhero I can do this I'm saving
Christmas
all right which one of you gave a little
kid
explosives allow me to break the ice
little Batman everybody in here what do
you say need a wing
man more like a sid
[Music]
kick every everybody listen this is
important I'm going to show you guys
something and when I show you what I'm
going to show you don't freak
out I can
explain it's It's Beginning to Look a
Lot Like Christmas high stakes as
neighbors compete for best decorated
house on the Block I think this is the
house to
beat wow what's your Christmas wish
I just want to win this
[Music]
thing I'll take
it signature please ignore all the fine
print it's like you're signing your life
away Merry Christmas yeah Merry
Christmas oh it will
[Laughter]
be rise and shine Naughty
Boy what the hell is all of
this something's happening good morning
sir are you real we all were until we
fell into that elf's sck
trap you made your wish you're in it now
I didn't sign on for this you literally
signed on for this you got to read the
fine print man the terms of service are
brutal say goodbye to your
dad why are y'all just like
Prince we are not going to let her turn
your dad into one of those weird Happy
Meal toys no offense I'm sorry n a
little
taken we are the
Carvers we got to catch an
Al you met with the wrong
family we should split up what do you
mean we should split up have you never
watched a horror film if you split up
somebody dies have you ever died oh it
is not fun that's true I've never died
but Mom knows I didn't know you'd been
let's go find these
[Music]
Rings is that who I think it it is oh my
God Black Santa I knew Santa was black
[Music]
man the great Adrien monk for a while
there you were solving a major case
every week I couldn't have done it alone
I could have but it would have taken
longer I have traumatic symptoms
unprecedented in psychiatric
history he's afraid of heights it's his
second biggest fear after germs actually
goes germs needles Birds then
Heights that was no accident he was
murdered you have to help me turn turn
it turn it turn it there's a bomb
there's a bomb you're not
helping we should leave a
note when Co hit I was in bad shape this
is
mine look at us everybody's you they're
going to hate it here's what happened so
how does that feel to be working again
like riding a bicycle
oh I'm glad to hear that I mean it's
[Music]
terrifying
silent
night
holy night what's up
roomie get ready it's Christmas Eve have
you been good last year not exactly
naughty but definitely gross for the
naughtiest have I ever sh you
wrong a bunch of times nicest what could
be better than being snowed in with your
family for the
holidays Limpus I think my freckles
might have frost bite do not make eye
content Christmas ever read about this
family that got Snowden and to survive
they had to eat each other F streaming
on Disney plus Del friendo is one of
Santa's most important Scouts it's
alive really come on Diary of a Wimpy
Kid Christmas Cabin Fever streaming on
Disney
[Music]
[Applause]
plus okay stay close let's
[Music]
go my how y'all doing
are y'all from England uh Australia
Australia wish sh had an
accent dad I wrote a song thought maybe
we could ask for an audition oh that's
great honey let's take it one step at a
time okay tells me you're a promoter you
know someone looking for it well I may
know somebody who should
be she's been given a beautiful voice
it's a miracle she's a special one son
your family they're not in the way they
are the
way there's no food and we're almost out
of money we need to make some changes
kids we need your
help this is everything we have and
sometimes it's going to grow and
sometimes it will shrink but it cannot
be allowed to
[Music]
disappear I wonder if he's right maybe
I'm not meant to
or maybe you're not meant to sing other
people's
songs it's going to be dangerous and
scary and giving up giving in it's not
an
option whatever your dream is I know you
can achieve it please welcome my big
sister the dream is to be like you it
always has
[Music]
been I want to reord D so do I yeah well
boys get in
[Music]
line show starts in 1
minute to
the to the L let's all go to the lobby
to get
ourselves
someone is killing my
children someone help on uprooting life
in Fairwood as we know and making us
forget who we are and where we've come
from right now right
now and now on with the show
pay attention fool you're about to see
what it means to be a hero you're the
only one who can save me I can't take
any more pies in the face I'm tired of
being rescued I want to do the
rescuing I'm
done are you going to tell me what
you're up to I am going on a quest to
make something of my life I give him 45
minutes
tops
[Music]
I know you you're the dude from the play
who keep catching p in the face I'm DJ
doggy
dog this something seriously wrong with
this
[Music]
guy why are you smiling we've got to
save the baby raccoons DJ everyone loves
baby
raccoons I can't go rescue them the plan
is to improvise that's not a play OD
word can't get
w
your imagination makes you move
Mountain a mighty
whale this was a bad
idea I'm your friend grab my hand and
trust
me Rhymes you catch if we rap battle
I'll win the match when I see your
turntable I we
SC what on the street is your daughter's
coming home she's all no style don't
talk about my daughter man don't look at
her I'm sure your dad's going to love
you bringing home a gringo boyfriend
everyone knew his daughter loved her new
man a lot my dad loves
surprises I hate
surprises got to stay sober this
year a
you but not everyone knew I have a
surprise for you Mom Dad this is my
boyfriend your boyfriend Oak vas your
Sanchez puppy did not family meeting in
the Mexican home right
now what are you doing here I would like
to ask for your daughter's hand in
marriage Mr Sanchez from the director of
From Prada
Tada that I wanted a Brown Christmas
not a white Christmas I want a
traditional
Christmas Dad how come you never liked
any of my boyfriends what about ja yet
it's Min Mario Lopez hey throw me a bear
claw hey fool you on a diet remember
he's smart he's got a good job damn he's
handsome and is gay he's gay is
[Music]
gay I think I straight my back slow down
I know what I'm doing I got this this
way
okay
don't you think you're overreacting a
little bit your father doesn't like me
he just needs to get to know you time
for you to play the game of the Gods
it's a very dangerous game so you're
going to have to follow my
LEAP because of this Greeno right here
I've been humiliated in front of my
family not on my Christmas the party was
whack full we weren't
invited he asked you for Claudia Cy
marriage okay this is a season to be
married not to get
married check it out he's MadAss son
I'm mad at your mom for having
you what do you think red white and
green D It's Christmas not Jesus was
Mexican it was my job to protect my rose
Christmas was for
[Music]
family how the Greeno Stole Christmas
Christmas ain't over yet eh mer
Christmas don't smoke it
[Music]
everybody